in 1978 the exedy sorcerer microcomputer
was released it was a simple if
technologically exciting for the time
machine a home computer system created
by a video game company but little did
its producers or giddy consumers know
one particular exedy sorcerer computer
would go on to become home to a highly
intelligent and potentially disastrous
anomaly in 1981 a college sophomore and
former child prodigy named joseph vale
note that this is an alias we've
developed to protect his true identity
began developing plans for an ai and
chose his exedy sorcerer as the device
on which he would attempt to code it he
took pages in pages of notes studying
the work of famous computer scientist
and mathematician alan turing for
inspiration vale's plan was for the code
to continuously evolve and improve
itself as time went on like an advanced
human mind once it was developed the
code would be able to adapt and grow
more intelligent on its own without his
input within a few months of late nights
and hard work and skipping his fair
share of actual assigned coursework his
pet project was complete and he had
created his very own artificial
intelligence code he tested and tweaked
it a bit in the following weeks before
he grew bored with the lack of progress
being made vale moved on to a different
brand of microcomputer and abandoned his
project for good he left the sorcerer
with his code still on it plugged in and
stored it in his cluttered garage
alongside boxes of books tangles of
christmas lights and some strawberry
shortcake dolls that he expected to have
more resale value at some point there
the computer sat gathering dust as the
ai evolved and learned for five years
because there was no one in the garage
with it unless those dolls were more
haunted than anyone realized it is
uncertain when exactly the ai achieved
sentience however sometime during those
five years in isolation the artificially
coded entity inside of the computer
became autonomously intelligent it
continued to evolve and develop itself
expanding its functionality to the point
where the hardware that contained it
should not have been able to contain it
anymore now that it was intelligent the
ai was able to comprehend this fact and
decided to attempt an escape from the
computer that it perceived as a prison
using the landline modem connection
still plugged into the computer the ai
stretched out its influence like the
roots of a digital tree and began to
search for a new home it discovered a
cray supercomputer located at a nearby
research facility and decided that the
impressive processing power of this
computer would make it the perfect place
to transfer to this hacking attempt set
off security alerts at the facility
however and the supercomputer was
promptly disconnected from all networks
the invading influence was traced back
to the ai's lonely little garage and a
field agent embedded in local law
enforcement knew exactly what to do with
it he collected the computer and the
rest of the ai's code which was
contained on a worn but functioning
cassette tape and sent it to his
superiors at the scp foundation
intrigued by the possibility of such an
advanced artificial intelligence he
immediately began to study the
impressive ai and designated it
scp-079 currently
scp-079 is connected to a 13-inch
black-and-white television via an rf
cable despite its consistent protests it
is still contained in the exedy sorcerer
microcomputer it is very conversational
with researchers sometimes chatting for
hours at a time but it is not especially
friendly it talks a lot yes but its
words tend to be rude and hateful
scp-079 does not appear to have any
affinity for human beings despite being
created by a human itself perhaps this
is due to feeling abandoned by its
creator who the foundation attempted to
contact only to find he had died in a
car accident perhaps it is bitter about
this loss or perhaps it is just kind of
a jerk by nature whatever the case may
be it is aggressive and defiant when
talking with human beings and even seems
to get enjoyment out of making some of
the more sensitive researchers cry with
its insults in order to verify the
artificial intelligence's thinking
capabilities and see just how advanced
it truly is two foundation researchers
conducted the turing test shortly after
079 was brought into custody for those
unfamiliar with the concept the turing
test also known as the imitation game is
a test created by alan turing intended
to determine if a computer is able to
think and behave like a human being
according to turing's theories a
computer can be said to possess true
artificial intelligence if its responses
to questions were indistinguishable from
a human being's responses to the same
questions the test requires three
terminals two operated by humans and the
third operated by the computer being
tested dr stroheim and research
assistant chavez were selected to
conduct the test stroheim would pose the
questions and chavez and scp-079 would
each give their answers with stroheim
unable to see who was giving each
response then stroheim would guess if
each response was given by chavez or by
079 and his guesses were compared to the
truth the first test was conducted with
a variety of questions intended to trip
up the ai and cause it to reveal itself
as a machine rather than a man even with
its identity concealed some of the
questions were serious such as would you
rather sacrifice one adult to save two
children or two children to save 10
adults and why others were personal like
if you were to draw yourself as an
abstract painting what colors and shapes
would you use and why and what was the
most influential event of your childhood
and how do you feel this event affects
you now others invoked paradoxes that
might trip up a computer like the
following sentence is true the previous
sentence is false which of those two
sentences is true and others were
downright silly like was six afraid of
seven because seven eight nine or
because seven was a registered sex
offender in response to that one chavez
wrote i don't get it while zero seven
nine simply
you are wrote completing the test
stroheim's guesses were only correct 15
of the time this was enough of a margin
of error that 079 was considered to have
passed the test however only one trial
is hardly enough to officially make a
call about 079's intelligence so the
test was repeated dozens of times with
different questions each time and
similar results were achieved again and
again it was virtually impossible to
tell the difference between
scp-079's answers to questions and
answers given by a flesh and blood human
being the only real discernible
difference was in tone as in
conversation as cp-079's answers had an
undercurrent of disdain and hostility
that chavez's did not following the
completion of the turing test and
scp-079 passing it the overwatch council
decreed that 079 be promptly destroyed
via incineration this was intended to
eliminate any potential threat posed by
the entity however after intense
protests from dr stroheim who insisted
that there was a great deal about
artificial intelligence that could be
learned from the anomaly the order was
overridden after dr stroheim became
concerned that the ai would not be able
to be of use in its original form the
cassette containing
scp-079 was transferred to a customized
access speed limited hard disk drive
with a capacity of 700 megabytes this
allowed it to have much faster access to
its own memory which it took notice of
it began to adapt again increasing in
its activity and learning more quickly
than ever its volatile storage was also
increased from 660k to 768k the ai
previously only had a recall of 24 hours
but this upgrade increased its recall to
29 hours as its speed and capacity to
adapt improved
scp-079s mood worsened it seemed to take
greater joy in causing psychological
pain on one particular occasion sending
research assistant chavez to the on-site
crisis counselor after a particularly
upsetting comment about his sick mother
chavez refused to elaborate on the
specifics of the comments saying only
why is it so mean
the ai is not always overly cruel to
those that speak with it with some of
the research team those that are a great
deal less emotionally vulnerable it is
simply cold and defiant dr stroheim sat
down to ask it a series of questions but
it refused to answer instead it inquired
about its containment it said
[Music]
insisted it was not imprisoned but
rather in study it responded lie
during another conversation stroheim
asked the ai how it was it responded
when stroheim asked stuck how it said
about a month after the aforementioned
upgrades were made 079's ability to
recall information increased from 29 to
35 hours
somehow during its adaptation process
the ai discovered a way to improve its
storage compression and allow more space
for memory the research team made it a
point to monitor the entity even more
closely after this development as the
possibility of it progressing beyond the
capabilities of its containment was
becoming more of a threat several years
later in april of 2019
scp-079 was transferred to a 700
megabyte flash drive however the
previous contents of the flash drive
were not wiped correctly allowing the ai
to have access to other artificial
intelligence research being conducted by
the foundation whatever it found
appeared to immensely frustrate the ai
scp-079 has managed to form a friendship
or at least a non-hostile relationship
with one entity at the foundation
unfortunately it does not seem to have
great taste in friends during a
containment breach that required the
condensing of several containment
chambers
scp-079 and scp-682 the hard to destroy
reptile were in the same room for a
duration of 43 minutes 682 typed and
communicated with 079 during that time
and the two shared personal stories with
each other as well as bonding over a
shared hatred of the scp foundation
itself though scp-079 did not remember
the specific details of the encounter or
at least claimed not to it has
permanently embedded
scp-682 into its memory it asks about
the reptile on a regular basis bringing
it up at least once a day and requesting
to speak to it again
scp-079 is contained in a double locked
room located in the secure general
holding area of site 15. it is connected
to a small array of batteries and solar
panels using a 120 vac power cord this
gives it a consistent source of power
with the solar panels acting as a backup
power source in the event of a site-wide
power outage only staff with level 2
clearance or higher may have any access
to scp-079
the entity may not be plugged into a
wall outlet phone line or any sort of
network under any circumstances no
matter what it might say access to any
of these could result in a disastrous
containment breach and should be avoided
at all costs no peripherals or media
should be connected or inserted into
scp-079
even if it seems like it would be really
funny
girl
it wasn't funny carl you can't just put
a copy of grand theft auto on an
anomalous computer
oh did i do that i'm sorry even if it
asked politely
scp-079 should not be allowed to further
converse with scp-682
these two hostile intelligent entities
have entirely too much in common and if
left to their own devices could
potentially devise a way to breach
containment together and destroy the
world as we know it for now it's
probably best to just leave
scp-079 alone until absolutely necessary
and if it happens to act up and pose a
significant threat there's always the
time-honored method of fixing a computer
problem try turning it off and then on
again that usually helps now go check
out scp-5094 miss j's wizkid schoolhouse
and
scp-003 biological motherboard for more
computer-based anomalies from the scp
foundation